the Washington Wizards dance team for
seniors and showing fans you are only as
old as you feel the dancer is called the
wisdom are all at least age 15 some are
much older Jan Crawford caught up with
the team and tried out some of their
moves
she's with the wisdom at Capital One
Arena in DC where the Wizards play hey
Jan can't wait to see your moves well
you know I don't know about that but
listen I got to say move over Laker
Girls because the NBA team in this town
is taking a more mature approach with
the wisdom yeah they're a dad's today
mostly women and as you said some are in
their 50s but others are all the way up
to 76 and they're taking the floor to
show that you are never too old to have
fun in a sports with so much skin in the
game this NBA team is adding can we say
it a new wrinkle meet the wisdom the
Washington Wizards are courting new fans
with this senior dance team you have to
be over 50 to join but make no mistake
they're hardly retiring when you're out
there dancing you're saying like hey
guys
64 years old you can do anything BAM I
don't accept the boundaries of age
period
my husband's 18 years younger I don't
know who they say you can't do this is
because I want him to come and we'll
have a chat
Teresa siz Mar says this helped her
through the recent death of her nephew
and diagnosis with breast cancer I mean
who knew that I was supposed to get
through cancer me
let's just keep stepping
yeah yeah the wisdom take the court at
one game a month with 19 women and right
there up front one guy I'm a huge huge
dance fan up and dance and my purse
would see you coming out the crib but at
53 Christopher Johnson says this is his
first time dancing in front of an
audience it's a dream it's really a
dream it's really a dream the team's
been a dream for so many members take
the court in a sport where the players
keep getting younger and provide a
silver lining of senior dance squads
across the league who like the wisdom
jump through some hoops to get here
first tryouts
then weekly workouts after 40 you're
like imma do me Lulu Hester Alexander
was inspired to try out by her
granddaughter Jasmine a Wizards dancer
sometimes the dance moves they deal I'm
like oh my god I never won and often
it's the wisdom who connect with the
fans in the stands
I think cuz we're more like them you
know they see themselves it's like well
if you can do it then I can do it I look
out for people that are kind of looking
and dancing with me and I throw a little
face their way bring them in I've rigged
them in and in a recent wisdom practice
that's what they did with me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see these women could not have been more
welcoming to even to a novice like me so
you know I've never had quite this much
fun on a story and I got to say tryouts
are coming up I may be back on this
Court can you would look good and well
you should get an honorary tracksuit
like that because that's awesome but we
really just say go Chan go Jan Jan and
Teresa I think that after 40 you're like
I'm going to do me we need to make a
billboard that says that I like that
that's a very common phrase just do you
just do you I like Teresa Terra amazing
amazing game just to watch them I would
do it if my son and daughter wouldn't be
mortified Kirby what would be so
embarrassed I think it looks fun
Oh like that stopped you in the past
also true Thank You Jan and thanks with
all team